Film Courage: Markus regarding connections,
I have a quote here (I don’t know who said
it) “Connections are good but nobody is
going to put their business in jeopardy because
of a connection.”
Markus Redmond, Writer/Director/Actor: That’s
absolutely true.
Film Courage: Did you say it?
Markus: No…no…wait…did I?
No I didn’t.
Film Courage: I don’t know where we got
this quote.
Markus: It’s true though.
It’s a business, especially now.
And it’s become a very risk-adverse business,
especially now because people don’t like
going to the movie theater unless SPIDER-MAN
is there.
So studios are spending the money where the
money is going to get spent.
So you can know Lorenzo di Bonaventura (one
of the guys who runs Warner Brothers) and
you can be like “Hey man, I know you are
doing a lot of stuff right now.
I’ve got this musical about socks.”
Lorenzo is probably going to say “You keep
that to yourself.”
You know what I mean?
It’s a business and it’s shifting daily
especially now with all of the streaming wars
going on and everyone is upset with Netflix.
They are pulling their content off of Netflix
and starting their own steamers and they are
trying to brand themselves.
This is what we do.
This is what we don’t do.
Counter-branding against that to get their
own.
A lot of money at stake.
A lot of it’s business.
If what you do lines up with their business
model, cool.
It doesn’t mean you’re not talented.
It doesn’t mean that what you do isn’t
great.
It means it doesn’t fit them.
I just had a pitch meeting that went amazing
at major place.
And the executives were totally into what
we had done and they thought it was really
funny and timely.
But they are rebranding.
Their brand is this.
My stuff was this.
So they are like “It’s great.
The writing is great.
It’s going to be a fun show.
It’s not for us.”
And that’s fine because everybody is doing
what they need to do for their business.
I don’t advocate doing or changing your
stuff to fit somebody’s business.
But it doesn’t hurt to sort of pay attention
to what network, studios, cablers, streamers.
What are they doing and what do I have in
my arsenal.
Where does this fit?
Where does this make sense?
You know what I mean?
Because you’re in business too.
Your business is getting your brand out there.
And there is somewhere for every brand.
You’ve got a brand, they’ve got a brand.
You’ve just got to find a brand that links
up.
So that’s my very long winded answer to
that question.
Film Courage: So when someone says “Now
I’m mad because Person B won’t help me
get to Person A and now I’m mad and they’re
just trying to hold me down and this industry
is no good.
Everybody is just out for themselves…”
Is that really it or is it that we all have
our own name and reputation at stake, “I’d
love to help you but…”
Markus: For that person, yes it’s true because
they’ve made a decision to see it that way,
for them it’s true.
It’s absolutely true.
The great thing about being a human being
with a brain is you get to decide how you
see things.
You get to choose how you react to what happens
to you.
So you can decide “Well this is a bummer.
It’s never going to happen.
Everybody bums me out.”
You can take the script, put it in a box under
your bed, walk around and be mad.
Or you can say “Okay, those are two people
in an industry with thousands of people and
some how my work made me a film.
Which means it probably will make me another
film.”
So I guess what I can do keep going and find
another spot, another avenue, another outlet,
another way to get this material that I believe
into the right hands.
The right hands is super important because
it’s not just about getting the thing set
up, getting the thing sold.
You can get the thing set up, get the thing
sold and if it’s in the wrong hands, it’s
going to be crap.
You need to be able to lock in with whoever
is going to be working with you to bring the
thing to fruition.
That’s what makes a film or a show great
because everybody (for the most part) gets
on the same page.
There are always disagreements “Well I think
this should happen.
I think this character should be here and
not there.”
It’s just part of it.
But if the overall goal is the same, that’s
what you want.
So if Person B cannot take you to Person A
(or will not take you to Person A), it’s
not the right fit.
There’s a good fit that is out there, it’s
just not this person.
And this person might be a better fit for
that other thing you’ve got so make sure
you’ve got another thing.
I tell writers all of the time that if you
want to get cooking and you’ve got a script
you dig, that’s awesome.
You should never stop, but you should have
something else.
Because again brains, people could be like
“I’m not into this but I like the writing.
What else you got?”And then if you don’t
have anything else and they are just sitting
there…remember the attention span is very
short.
So if you can’t come back and say “Oh
yeah, I’ve got another thing.
Why don’t we talk next week about the new
thing?”
People forget, people see a lot of people,
especially executives.
The scripts they have to read, the pitches
they hear, all of the continual stuff coming
at them.
It’s very, very rare for these guys to remember
this one specific thing that I saw three months
ago.
They can, it happens if it really stood out
to that one person but you know…better your
odds.
Just keep making content, keep working (I
think).